- Hallo.
- Guten Tag, Ihre Bestellung.
Zahlen Sie zusammen oder getrennt?
- Zusammen. Was kostet das?
- Gut, Moment. Die drei Pizzen mit
Salami sind 22,50 Euro.
Dann haben wir eine Pizza Thunfisch,
eine Pizza Hawaii ohne Schinken, 18 Euro.
Das macht zusammen … 40,50 Euro.
Zahlen Sie bar oder mit Karte?
- Ähm, ich zahle bar. Hier sind 45 Euro.
Das stimmt so.
- Danke! Hier ist die Rechnung.
Tschüss.
- Danke.
- So … Wer bekommt die Hawaii
ohne Schinken?
- Ich!
- Tonno?
- Ja!
- Salami?
- Salami, ich!
- Salami! Und noch eine Salami.
- Wie viel kostet die Pizza?
- Zehn Euro plus Trinkgeld.
Und du bist eingeladen!
- Danke schön!
- Das ist vielleicht die letzte Pizza,
die ich hier essen werde.
- Stimmt.
- Nawin geht weg.
- Das ist eine Bye-bye-Party?
- Eine Abschiedsparty.
- Abschiedsparty.
- Guten Appetit jetzt!